real quickly we were just curious how
you got started I know you had a film in
was it 2011 with Jonah Hill that you
wrote with your partner Alessandra yes
well actually I met Alessandro at
Columbia Film School where he graduated
with distinction and I dropped out but
we had already started writing together
and working together and we started
writing I guess our first professional
job was probably around 2005 or so we
started working for Warner Brothers and
then we spent many years doing a number
of different you know rewrites on
scripts we do adaptations we do punch
ups and then you know you altima t had a
had an original that we wrote The Sitter
that came out and it it was a lot it was
a lot of writing a lot of hard work to
break in it's it's not easy but um you
know getting inside the studio system
was actually an advantage for us and
that we were essentially paid to to work
on writing for a number of years and
hone skills and take on dinners on rows
and sort of build up a toolbox of
writing so it was ultimately great but
it was a grind
to it for sure I know you've been
writing together for what is it over a
decade or so yeah gosh it's been a long
time we we have met in our first writing
class at Columbia and we just had
similar taste we liked each other's
scripts and a second year we we decided
to try to write something together which
it turned out to be much more fun to
write with a partner than to sit in a
room by yourself all day it's tough to
find a partner and a lot of times I
think that people try to do with friends
but that doesn't really work I think
it's more important that you see film or
television in the same way of similar
worldview similar sense of humor and so
we weren't really friends we just liked
each other's work um but I mean we've
obviously kind of become friends over
the years we're very different people I
if you were here he would tell you that
also but we have a meet
respect for each other and we've had a
great you know probably almost 12 years
or decade plus at least writing career
together so it's been great that's great
I mean you hear about in the startup
world that co-founder breakups are the
number one reason something will fail so
it sounds like if at least if you can
work together maybe being best friends
at the time is is maybe a detriment cuz
you don't want to hurt one other's
feelings right
yeah no it's I'm not sure we just fell
into a natural rhythm of not having egos
and being able to criticize each other
or praise each other without you know
taking it personally and being able and
we also work you know very specific
hours so that we come in and we treat it
like a real job and then we're sort of
in the moment for you know six or eight
hours are hungry many hours writing a
day and then you know we kind of just go
our separate ways and yes we have become
friends because our wives are my friends
so that's why yeah yeah I did ask him to
be in my wedding years ago and he said
really don't you want to ask somebody
else to be my writing but again maybe
that's there's a little bit of a
separation and some sense that works
yeah it's really just because he's lazy
yeah I don't think it had anything to do
with just I'm just kidding he's very
he's a good guy but yeah when we have we
have a a very professional relationship
before also good friends I was wondering
is one of you more the rebellious writer
and the other ones more follows like
certain a guru you know and it's
automatic I think
that's a that's a tough question I'm not
sure how to answer it because we've just
fallen into a natural working
relationship I think that Alex probably
is more like let's just sit down do it
to shut up let's just do it and I like
to you know really challenge every idea
and make sure we're you know taking the
right path but it's a great mix because
it sort of keeps each other on our toes
you know I think that one more just like
two right away and the other maybe let's
just think about it for a second it's a
good push-pull sure yeah opposite
personality that works yeah so then with
comrade detective how did this come
about how the idea um well we grew up
fans of you know eighties entertainment
that was ultimately kind of propaganda
sort of the Red Dawn type movies and I
love those movies we both love those
movies growing up and you know we
thought about what it would be like from
the other side you know like a Soviet
perspective and sort of an exploration
of propaganda and you know we looked at
global television and we kind of found
this world that we didn't really know
existed even and there's a there's a PBS
documentary from the mid 80s about the
University of Minnesota that intercepted
Soviet satellite sort of network
television and they studied it for a
year and they would do a show on it
every week and it was a fascinating sort
of parallel universe that you know when
I was a kid there were kids on the other
side of globe growing up with an
entirely different perspective
and we also found there's a show called
the 30 cases of major Zeeman from
czechoslovakia that was a show about a
communist detective and it was entirely
made by the state in order to prop up
communist ideals he was sort of like the
communist James Bond and we just thought
that you know that was I guess it
touched on early on but um once we came
around that we were gonna make our own
fo sho
that's when you know Reese came on and
then we started developing the whole
thing together and you know when I'm in
sort of a surprising and fun journey and
an interesting process of making
something that we presuppose existed and
then you know all the way from making a
show in Romania through the dubbing
process which was totally experimental
process as well I know with documentary
now you're getting into the mind of the
original creator how was that - for you
I mean were you thinking of some of that
afterward you just like said let's sit
down and write this first um we tried to
write it from the from a point of view
of of you know communist filmmaker
making something that's that's
propaganda I think that you you
naturally are grow up with with a
worldview er or sort of your own
indoctrination that's probably
impossible to entirely shed but we did
try to really think about it from the
inverse perspective of if we were making
something from an American point of view
and how do you take turns riding or do
you sit is there like a favorite place
you go to together we probably spend
about 90 percent of the time riding in
the same room we feel like it keeps us
we're moving ahead and also we talk
through everything first so we never
really sit down without knowing what's
the other ones doing and then we'll
usually will either break stuff up or
one of them will take the one of us will
take the first step and then the other
will come in and just start rewriting it
right away we generally like to write
what we call a vomit draft just to try
to get get something out on paper right
away and that can sometimes be very
close to what ends up and sometimes it
can be entirely different but um it's
it's important to just start getting
your thoughts out on paper but yeah it's
it's um it's a we pretty much split up a
lot of the duties so it's still
interesting I've never had this before
oh yeah those curious who typed and by
you know type yeah I have a trick if we
have a deadline I generally just use
that you're faster I think I think I
read once that that's what you I can be
wrong but I think that II think Owen is
the faster type or so that that's what
I've read anyway but um but he is he's
like a magician so if there's a deadline
I usually use it and he's completely on
to it so he'll you generally pushback or
blink now it's it's all used stuff so
it's it's a it's a trick that I use too
many times but but I'll still still pull
it out every now and then but yeah we
it's it's a just a natural flow
situation there's no there's no rigid
rules or but yeah it's a little bit
tough to describe even I guess
you